our next
speaker broke his
femur which cut short his very promising
math leet
career so he now tries to protect his
data science career more by doing safer
activities such as snowboarding and auto
racing please welcome Joe hello
everybody
yes go for it Jared are you the one that
set the agenda I feel like boss is a
lose lose situation if I do poorly
you're unhappy and if I do too well that
I upstaged
you get it get on with
it all right I'll use the arrow
keys
okay so obviously I work for Jared I'm a
data scientist so this presentation is
going to be a bit of a boots on the
ground approach to a specific topic I
also work uh as a research scientist at
NYU so hence the kind of disheveled work
look compared to our other presenter so
today I'm going to talk about GitHub
actions uh and I apologize if this kind
of appears as a ad for Microsoft because
it's it's a bit of a love story but
before I get into it I think any data
scientist there's a few like pivotal
moments in in your learning process uh
you come across certain tools like say r
or python uh you know excellent
scripting languages for that enabled so
much to do uh ggplot 2 the great package
that allows you know visualization of
your data and so much more and then
shiny a really powerful web framework
for building these you know interactive
web applications and then finally coming
from a statistics background you know
just statistics an ml all these
different algorithms that allow you to
help predict and explain the world
around us but I want to add one more
thing which is GitHub
actions so what is GitHub actions well
imagine you have computing power I like
to call this you know the Raspberry Pi
in the sky this is easy to
use it's free in many cases you can
scale up and start paying if you'd like
but it's excellent to begin with uh it's
at your fingertips you know it's easily
accessible and you can set it on a
schedule it's automated it's schable you
can set it up so when you push your code
it executes right then and finally you
know it's no no to little
maintenance so how would you use this
well just like a Raspberry Pi there's
almost an unlimited amount of
opportunities to use it for but most
people use it for doing what I think is
kind of boring boring things running
unit tests you know checking package
code deploying packages these are all
really useful things they're actually
you know exceedingly useful and have
change Industries uh and is what cicd is
for you know the talk about this is you
know
cicd CI can do more and there's just
more to cicd than just
this so it's all a bit uncreative all a
bit boring but you know sometimes boring
things are good and our ecosystem
there's a great Community around GitHub
actions here we have a yaml file and you
can kind of view this as the instruction
set for GitHub actions so all these are
kind of various steps that do something
for you this one here sets up an R
environment so like a Raspberry Pi in
the sky you get a blank machine that
does whatever you want it to do here you
know it installs R and then you have to
do what you will with it and there's
various other you know scripts yo files
that do things for you set up R
environment set up packages you're using
RM in the r world uh that does it for
you here we check an r package these are
all things you don't have to write this
yourself you pull this off the community
and it does it for you so these are very
useful they're pre canned it's not just
R there's equivalent in many other
languages and what that work workflow
looks like as a developer is something
that people are already very used to so
you
code you commit your code as you do with
your repo and you push that up to GitHub
and really the magic is things that you
don't see once you have this set up it
executes for you so every time you push
you can have it so it executes code so
imagine you write an r
package you make some changes to that r
package you commit that you push that up
to GitHub GitHub actions sets up a
machine for you installs that r package
runs those checks and you either pass or
don't pass those checks that's kind of a
traditional cicd
approach but like I said it's kind of
boring there's many more things that you
can do with get up
actions and really it's up to you so one
good example that we often use it for is
pulling down API data so imagine you
need to Source some data from somewhere
be it weather data from open Weather you
need every single day pull down weather
for say Tampa and then store that in
your own database for use later
on you could also hit financial data you
hit open AI API whatever API you'd like
as long as you can write a script for it
you could access it you can do it for
more traditional things but I often list
this because many data scientists don't
do this you could deploy dashboards so
you build your dashboard you commit you
push it passes your checks and then
deploys it to somewhere like shiny apps.
IO or your own
server but today I want to show you
something a little more unique you can
actually use GitHub actions for
refitting models originally fitting your
models and then also scoring your data
and you could score it however often you
like you could set it on a you know
daily basis a monthly basis an hourly
basis whatever works for
you so here's the problem you may face
imagine that you just built a great
custom forecasting algorithm to predict
the next 30 days of
sales you've already done all the hard
work and like Jared said in the last in
the last talk this is pretty in-depth
right so there's many different steps to
this one as a data science scientist
you're probably familiar with the first
being sourcing your data hitting apis
going out to the outside world getting
data where you where you need it from
cleaning that data you know that's often
80 90 95% of your work as a data
scientist setting your exous variables
so these are your
predictors fitting your models so going
through for forecasting ARA Auto ARA gam
profit you know rnns anything that you
want remember this is custom this is you
writing these scripts getting it done
cross validating all those models so
ultimately you can get to the point
where you pick the best
one setting your evaluation metrics r
map again choose whatever you like given
your background and
expertise and then finally selecting
that best
model and making forecasts from that
best model nothing unique here if you're
if you know forecasting this is probably
a relatively standard approach to
building an
algorithm and perhaps you wrap this all
into one R script or a python script so
this is a lot of work done so far so you
know B s on the back this probably takes
weeks months you know quite a bit of
time but you really having to address
probably your core business
organizational problem which is that you
need to continuously predict the next 30
days of sales for it to be useful to
your business so how can you how can you
get that done because really what you
need to do you need to run it most
likely every single day and with that
you get model drift your model just
isn't as good you know today as maybe it
was yesterday
to address this of course you need data
every single day you need to score it
every single day and then on some
regular Cadence say monthly you're going
to have to refit that model to address
that model
drift so I'll give you a basic blueprint
as to how you can do this with GitHub
actions first instead of just having you
know one script structuring this in a
little more you know formal way and one
way to do this is to have a few
different scripts so you can
imagine one of my early steps getting
data that would be one script another
one would be a training another one
would be scoring that and making those
predictions now this is really up to you
as to how you like to structure your
structure your project and Jared
mentioned a great thing in the last talk
targets which I'll talk a little bit in
a moment about but generally you want to
have a more uh you know decoupled
approach to your
project
and here's really where the magic comes
in I showed those yl files earlier these
yl files are really the instruction set
GitHub actions re re relies on these yl
files and uh what you'll see here is
that this would live in your repo so we
have at the top you see it says. GitHub
workflows update weather that's the
directory that we would live in and
GitHub itself knows to look in here and
execute these files here so we give it a
name pull weather data from our API
and we we say okay here's one job that
we have we're going to call that update
weather weather and the first thing that
we're going to tell it is we want to run
this on a Linux machine you Bo to
running
22.4 and from here we're going to start
adding steps so our first step which is
the most common that you see pretty much
in every single yaml file is that you
check out the repo this is just saying
okay machine now you have Ubuntu after
you have ubu you know set up the first
thing you need to do is pull down the
repo
itself and have that code available to
you and from here since we're going to
be running a rscript we're going to use
a community file from the r lib actions
called setup R and it's a V2 version and
what this does it goes out to the
internet downloads R installs it on our
new Linux box and here we're telling it
install 4.2.3 because that's what we use
with our
project and then let's keep going
through these steps and it's actually
very simple here you know we only have
three we checked it out we set up our
and then finally we're just say Okay
Source our script so in the previous we
had our get data. R and we had our
train. R and we had our score. R here
we're just going to say set up and run
our get data so we execute that but we
really haven't done anything that
special here we have our machine it
executed it but it's not really helping
us because it's not scheduled GitHub
actions makes this really easy to
schedule here here we have Kon KRON
syntax so it may look funny if you're
not familiar with it but all it's saying
is run every day at 3:00
a.m. and that's basically it you know
this is 19 18 maybe less with Comet uh
lines of code and very very simple very
straightforward but there's really even
more features that you can do we
specified ubu on the last but you could
you could use Mac OS you could use other
flavors of Linux you could use other you
know versions of Ubuntu and of course
you could use Windows uh if you prefer
you can also like we showed schedule it
but you can also do on demand so if I
every time I push the code I can have it
execute
then and for free GitHub gives you I
believe three or four you know G it's
seven gigabytes of RAM now they've been
upgrading it 7 gab of ram now and you
know I think a dual core processor which
is fine for fitting many forecasting
models on a moderate amount of data but
for many use cases that probably won't
be enough so of course you can you know
cough up a little extra cash and they'll
give you a more powerful
machine and there's a great Community
around this uh R the steps that I was
using uses R lib libraries uh but
there's a whole Community around
different types of languages
and what I want to leave you with is
Jared talked a little bit about targets
about kind of having a a dag a directed
asil graph approach how you structure
your code this can really enhance how
you build your GitHub actions pipelines
because you know with just having three
files you know that get data that that
score and that those train files that
can get messy so what dags do for you
and in the world of r
targets is a great package for this uh
and here's a here's a short example so
imagine in your project you have a
handful of different functions and
different files that you're using here
we have plot model function a git data
function a fit model function and then
some data Maybe from a file and they
interact in this way uh but you can
imagine as you're working through this
and you're executing it uh some things
become out ofd and you don't want to run
everything all again so one of the main
features of Targets in this dag approach
is that it understands which data and
which files are out of date and when you
reschedule or rerun this it will only
run what's needed so in this case plot
model is now out of date because it's
light blue and if you reran this whole
pipeline then it would only execute plot
model and the plot function which is
it's depended
on but there's many other pipeline tools
available not just R and targets and you
can find these uh on the link AR
GitHub so what do we cover we covered
GitHub actions is just computing power
it's a Raspberry Pi in the sky that's
easy it's cheap it's at your fingertips
and it's automatable and
schedulable and you can do whatever you
like with it you can pull down API data
you can refit models you you can score
models and so it's really up to you as
to what you'd like to do with it and
with that I will end a little bit ear
because I think I'm holding everybody up
for lunch thank
you